[Music]
welcome back to Hannity now following
the New York City terrorist attacks some
predictably and sadly in the mainstream
media they're just having a hard time
understanding the mindset behind these
actions now shortly after the horrific
incident you have liberal fake news
CNN's fake Jake Tapper while he
described the phrase shouted by the
terrorists Allahu Akbar well he said
that sometimes can be something said in
beautiful circumstances let's play it
the FBI is taking over this case because
it appears now that this is terrorism
the Arabic chanda allahu akbar god is
great
sometimes said under the most beautiful
of circumstances and too often we hear
of it mean being said in moments like
this oh and they had a lower third on
CNN and it actually said oh the
terrorist was not terrorist so the
suspect was saying god is great in
Arabic well that's actually called
allahu akbar
now tapper has since been levying
multiple attacks on the fox news channel
reporting the comments in context that
you just listened to tweeted quote Fox
News is lying I said it can be said at
beautiful moments wedding birth and too
often at times like this horrific
terrorist attacks then he went on quote
and yes I know they do this all the time
still literally the day after this
horrific attack they would launch this
smear it's sick hey Jake maybe that's
why you have low ratings tell your
audience the truth and meanwhile look
mister thrill up his leg Chris Matthews
over a conspiracy TV MSNBC he asks why
the suspect might have anger towards us
in the US what's this as a Miss Becky
why would he have an animus toward the
United States do we have it has anything
to do with geopolitics over the former
Soviet Union
like those Chechens who created the
heart at the Boston Marathon a waitress
and to answer that question a good
question
you know he was earning a living here in
the United States earning a living as a
truck driver seems to have been
integrated into society really Chris
really this is a worldwide global
radical jihadist war that they're
fighting and have
been fighting for a very long time do
you remember 9/11 2001 wake up joining
us now we continue with the former
deputy assistant to the president
Sebastian Gorka and American first
action spokesman senior advisor former
Milwaukee County Sheriff David Clarke
Cheryl Clark it is rather mind-numbing
oh the chyron that says oh he said god
is great in Arabic we all know what
Allah ho Akbar the context in which this
was used in this case like it has been
used so many other times in the past
I ate Smee that the media in this
country they don't no longer care about
truth and facts and over their fake news
and over their conspiracy theory TV all
they care about Donald Trump and
destroying the president that's it
there's no truth anymore that they tell
their audience they're all a bunch of
sheep that report the same lies but
that's my feeling what's yours well
first of all it's shameful conduct on
the part of CNN MSNBC the New York Times
Washington Post Huffington polls they
become terrorist sympathizers but what
happened yesterday is what will happen
when you try to play social engineering
conduct social engineering experiments
with national security
look this diversity lottery when I first
heard that I said power balls run as a
more effective lottery than this thing
is you know there's attempt at diversity
you just cannot do this with national
security or domestic security culture
this this attempt at multiculturalism
has been a disaster cultures do not
blend they clash let me go to Sebastian
you know Sebastian when you were at the
White House I'd watch you do interviews
and you were once on the the fake news
Clinton news network and you actually
said the Cartoon Network gets higher
ratings than you guys do there's a
reason and by the way I'm not there's a
reason that they nobody wants to watch
them people no longer trust CNN they
don't trust conspiracy theory TV MSNBC
isn't that the real reason I just I'm
still trying to struggle with
what kind of mind goes on live
television as seven bodies are on the
streets of Manhattan and a child and
then talks about the beautiful phrase
all our walk by what where does that
motivation come from for Jake Tapper the
the the desperation of trying to explain
they did this because of animus to
America our foreign policy I've got a
newsflash for Matthews for Jake Tapper
for the former President United States
you know what why what happened
yesterday happened because they hate who
we are and what we stand for
we are the pinnacle of judeo-christian
civilization we believe in the dignity
of the individual we believe in liberty
and democracy that's why they are coming
here to kill us
President Obama yesterday tweeted after
the attack that an attack had happened
in Manhattan it wasn't an attack mr.
Obama
it was a jihadi terrorist attack yeah
last word sheriff Clark yeah it'sit's
interesting after all that has happened
around the world still people don't want
to use vetting they still don't want to
secure the border and I'm thinking these
policies now are endangering good
innocent Americans these people that
were mowed down yesterday riding their
bicycles taking a walk on a beautiful
autumn fall day it's just ridiculous to
me oh no doubt about it but there's some
good news here president Donald Trump is
the only elected official in the Beltway
in Washington DC who gets it I heard his
press conference this afternoon
it was brilliant it was spot-on not only
has he identified the enemy and
identified what the problem is and he
did it during his entire campaign I
think it's one of the big reasons he got
elected but he's also going to do
something about it I was great I was
glad to hear that he's gonna suspend
this crazy diversity lottery program
until Congress can get their act and
that's Acronis has been a problem to
both parties it refused to tackle
immigration to make this country safe
but you know like I said we got a
commander-in-chief now
was gonna do everything I like power to
keep us safe I love when the president
these are soulless animals if you can
mow down innocent people and slaughter
them you're evil
this is evil in our time let's wake up
for all the rest of you in the media
wake up
thank you both appreciate it we have so
much more to come I have a good news
announcement coming up later in the
program tonight we also you don't want
to miss a special Hannity investigation
into Robert Muller and the corruption
well investigate the investigators also
you know